Esta vez tenemos la ecuación 2x + y = 8, esta
es una única ecuación con dos incógnitas,
y existen varios pares diferentes de x y y que
satisfacen esta ecuación. Ahora agreguemos una
segunda ecuación: x + y = 5, una vez más si sólo
vemos en la segunda ecuación, existen varios pares
diferentes de x y y que las satisfacen. Por
ejemplo, si x = 4 y y = 1, si x = 3 y y = 2,
muchos demasiados, de hecho hay un número infinito
de pares distintos xy que pueden satisfacer esta
ecuación. Pero lo interesante de un sistema de
ecuaciones es que estamos usando ambas ecuaciones
como restricciones, es decir, vamos a pensar en lo
siguiente: ¿existirá al menos un par de x y y que
satisfaga a ambas ecuaciones? Y como veremos en
varios videos futuros, es muy útil pensar esto no
sólo en el área de las matemáticas sino en muchas
áreas del conocimiento en general. Pero en este
video nos vamos a enfocar en pensar por qué son
válidas e intuitivas las operaciones que podemos
realizar en una o ambas ecuaciones. En la primera
serie de operaciones intentaremos manipular una
sola ecuación, por ejemplo podemos multiplicar
ambos lados de la ecuación morada por -1,
entonces obtenemos -2x - y es igual a, y como
multiplicamos también el lado derecho por -1,
obtenemos -8. Ahora, todo lo que hicimos por aquí
podríamos hacerlo incluso si no tuviéramos un
sistema de ecuaciones. Decimos que es verdadero
que 2x + y = 8; estamos suponiendo que esto es
verdadero porque nos dicen que es verdadero, por
lo tanto si 2x + y es equivalente a 8, entonces
el negativo de 2x + y deberá ser equivalente a
-8. Otra forma de pensarlo es que si ambos lados
son iguales y multiplicamos el lado izquierdo por
algo, entonces, para que la igualdad se mantenga
verdadera, tenemos que multiplicar el lado derecho
por el mismo valor. Así que esta ecuación de la
derecha, esta ecuación en morado, es equivalente
a nuestra ecuación original; se ve distinta, pero
los mismos pares xy que satisfacen la ecuación
de la derecha van a satisfacer la ecuación de la
izquierda y viceversa. Ahora, otra operación que
a veces se siente un poco menos intuitiva cuando
la aprendes por primera vez al resolver sistemas
de ecuaciones es cuando sumamos dos ecuaciones.
Por ejemplo, tenemos esta ecuación en morado
que obtuvimos al multiplicar por -1 y también
tenemos nuestra ecuación original de color verde,
es decir, x + y = 5. Y cuando estamos resolviendo
sistemas de ecuaciones aprendemos que podemos
obtener una nueva ecuación al sumar los dos lados
izquierdos y los dos lados derechos de estas
ecuaciones, así que seguramente has visto algo
así. Si sumamos los dos lados izquierdos obtenemos
-2x + x = -x, y después -y + y, bueno, se van a
cancelar así que nos quedaremos sin y, y esto será
igual a -8 + 5, lo que es igual a -3. Y a antes de
terminar de resolver, ¿por qué podemos hacer esto?
Pausa el video y piénsalo. Bueno, déjame darte
un ejemplo. Si empezamos con -2x - y = -8 como
una única ecuación y sumamos 5 de ambos lados,
es decir, sumamos 5 del lado izquierdo y 5 del
lado derecho, obtenemos que -2x - y + 5 = -8 + 5.
Creo que esto será más intuitivo para ti porque,
una vez más -y sé que lo estoy repitiendo mucho-,
es verdadero que la parte izquierda es igual a -8,
entonces si sumamos 5 de ambos lados sigue siendo
verdadero que esta parte sea igual a -8 + 5. Ojalá
esto le dé un sentido más intuitivo, y lo que
debes darte cuenta en lo que hicimos aquí arriba
es que sumamos 5 de ambos lados. Podrías decir:
"Oye, pero sólo agregamos 5 en el lado derecho".
Pero recuerda, estamos diciendo que x + y = 5,
así que estamos agregando lo mismo de ambos lados
de la ecuación, por esto al sumar 5 de ambos lados
podemos eliminar esta variable y y ahora tenemos
una ecuación con una incógnita. Y a partir de
aquí podemos realizar operaciones algebraicas
válidas. Podemos decir: "Ok, queremos tener sólo
x de este lado, ¿qué tal si dividimos a ambos
lados entre -1? Y una vez más, ya que -x = -3,
si queremos dividir -x / -1, también tendremos
que dividir -3 / -1 para mantener la igualdad.
Entonces obtenemos que x = 3. Por lo tanto,
este será el valor de x del par xy que satisface
ambas ecuaciones. Para encontrar el valor de y
podemos decir: "Bien, si ya sabemos que x = 3,
entonces regresemos a cualquiera de estas
dos ecuaciones para encontrar el valor de y
correspondiente". Bueno, es un poco más sencillo
regresar a la segunda ecuación; entonces diremos:
"Muy bien: 3 + y = 5, 3 + y debe de ser igual a
5; y por supuesto, si restamos 3 de ambos lados,
porque una vez más estamos diciendo que 3 + y
es literalmente igual a 5, entonces obtenemos
que y = 2. Con esto hemos encontrado un
par xy que satisface ambas ecuaciones,
y en realidad todo lo que escribimos por acá,
todos estos son enunciados equivalentes; uno
de ellos será verdadero, si y sólo si todos los
otros enunciados también son verdaderos. Entonces
2x + y = 8 y x + y = 5 si y sólo si x = 3 y y = 2
si y sólo si -2x - y = -8, si y sólo si y -x = -3.